مساء الخير مباشره ننتقل واياكم مشاهدينا
الى متابعه هذه الصور المباشره من العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس التي تشهد موجه جديده من
الاحتجاجات التي تضرب العاصمه باريس وايضا
مدن فرنسيه اخرى رفضا لرفع سن التقاعد
طبعا كنا قد تابعنا واياكم التصريحات
للحكومه الفرنسيه التي قالت بانها ستبقى
حصنه فرنسا ضد العنف المجموعات المتطرفه
كذلك وزير الداخليه الفرنسي كان قد حذر من
مخاطر حقيقيه للغايه مراسل العربيه حسين
قنيبر هذا اليوم ذكر بان هناك
وساطه يعني هذه تطبخ في فرنسا
طبعا حل هذا
الاشكال او هذا
الموضوع لكن الحكومه الفرنسيه
ان تقول باللا وساطه في وقت يمكن الحديث
بشكل مباشر مع جميع الفرنسيين كما في
الشريط الاخبار العاجله اسفل الشاشه اذا
موجه جديده من الاحتجاجات لليوم العاشر
والاضرابات كذلك على مستوى البلاد مسيرات
نتابعها واياكم الان على الشاشه
وفي هذه الصورتين المنقسمتين الان على
شاشه العربيه الحكومه الفرنسيه اذا انطلبت
من الاحزاب ومن القوى السياسيه ادانه
العنف والتاكيد على الفصل بين السياسه
والعنف كذلك كما نتابع واياكم في هذه
الصور اذا الحكومه الفرنسيه اكدت انها
ستبقى حصنه فرنسا ضد العنف والمجموعات
المتطرفه
العنيفه اذا هذه الاحتجاجات الرافضه لخطط
الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون للتاخير طبعا سن
التقاعد عامين ليصبح اربعه وستين عاما اذن
هذا هو القانون الجديد وهذه الاحتجاجات
التي
طبعا نشاهدها واياكم الان على الشاشه اذا
اليوم فرنسا تشهد يوما عاشرا من التظاهرات
ضد اصلاح النظام التقاعدي الذي تقابله
معارضه شعبيه كبيره كما نشاهد الان على
شاشه العربيه في جو روسيا بانه جو متوتر
يتننامى فيه هذا التوتر ازدياد اعمال
العنف التي تعمل الحكومه الفرنسيه على
تهدئتها كما قالت لكن حتى هذه اللحظه كما
يرى مراقبون دون جدوى الاحتجاجات تفاقمت
اليوم في اليوم العاشر طبعا لهذه
الاحتجاجات ضد التعديل الذي طرحه الرئيس
الفرنسي ورفع سن التقاعد من 62 عاما الى
64 عاما